[Music]
oh we are recording i mean yeah [ __ ] it
i don't care steve's doing a little
popping is this a good good guy right
here how is king listing today good
it's fun
it's
our flyer on the screen that was very
nice look at that it's very nice hey hey
listen
you don't want to ride home no no no you
guys well i wanted to give you a run
because i wanted to talk to you oh so
you want to wait okay you want me to
that'd be great okay no problem hell
yeah you're a legend hey
you know send brendan in
i'm not just sitting there just send
everybody in
do a little guest spot
dude that would be so if they do that i
would love that
yo we got a boost
you know what come on in who else is
here who else is going to come say hi i
know how the algorithm works man
featuring stevie
brendan
because we are recording we already
started yeah you know and that was i
thought that was a great intro uh you
got to see the the scissor bros
themselves yeah you saw them together
uh you should why not he wants to say hi
i don't care i haven't seen brandon in a
minute
do it just everybody
do it i love this i haven't seen them in
a minute yeah we're all gonna go we're
gonna say hi to jeremiah today
you know this is your pel's word we do
like i said i do the [ __ ] i want do
whatever you want i do whatever i want
yeah i am whoever i want
uh whatever way i want yeah whatever way
i want to look yup uh whichever way i
want to walk if i want to walk backwards
for a full day i'll walk backwards for a
full right we notice check it
out i didn't know they had them in nike
yeah dude i didn't know they had them in
nike's and i'm so excited and because
i'm like i'm like i feel like i'm the
only person in velcros oh another pump
oh my god nick this is the place
i feel like it's like one of those
disney shows where people pop in
the ultimate
who had to edit this put a big cheer
when i watched it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
we were just like a laugh yeah yeah
this is what this is this this is nick
nick davis yeah happy new year dude he's
amazing from the
lacrosse wisconsin he's the man he's the
deal oh wait why is it oh do we get to
see each other thank you nick for
stopping by man yeah nick stopped by oh
oh
my god
we have another puppet
ebony and ivory
[Laughter]
whoa yo this is all shades
this is all shades baby we look like the
evolution yeah over the evolution of
shades like if you guys had a baby
coming this far drifting everybody
hey let me know if you can do next week
yeah yeah yeah yeah next week look at
that look at that book
yeah after this one yeah yeah we'll do
right now and then the next one
the next one look at that who else we
got
who else we got i can't
yes sir nice to see you great to see you
bro look at that man man what are the i
told you man this is like one of those
this is gonna be the clip of the podcast
right here oh casey oh the producer
casey oh okay
okay what's up i just met casey but he's
flashing those scissors i like that
that's the guy that doesn't edit out my
fuck-ups whenever i [ __ ] up words he
doesn't
go you take that out he goes nope i'm
like all right casey edited in racial
slurs that's so weird that's so bizarre
how bizarre
i've already left
everyone
okay all right you got one last game one
last guess one let's pop in okay don't
know who it is i don't know who it is
let me know when it opens all right
should we open them now
wait wait wait wait wait
big boy
big thing super thick
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
no you're just we're gonna dance
no yeah this ain't that kind of [ __ ]
we're just doing a roll call
dude that's the best
faking like you're going to pull your
pants down and then calling somebody
else
y'all gay man you don't want to see this
dick
come on what are we doing here
everybody finally we have jarrah maya
walkers in the house host of jeremiah
wonders uh co-host of scissor bros with
stevie weeby and among many and many and
many of other things
this guy is amazing that is how you
intro a podcast right there that is that
hey that is the fun this is
this is my
you know beginning of the year for 2022
i'm gonna call it that might be the
intro of the year for podcasts for 2022
baby
we're going to use that
i love it i'm down dude how you doing
i'm doing great man i literally uh when
you hit me up i was like excited to see
you it's been a minute since yeah it has
been a minute yeah and dude i i i want
to talk about from the the first time
i mean we met a while back like a soft
meet you know real quick but i think
we've just always always known each
other you know through the social media
world and stuff yeah but the first uh
one of my first experiences to see you
in actual work
was well two two times first time was uh
i want to say i saw you open for bobby
lee at stand up live oh yeah that was
like
maybe 2017 or something like that i
can't remember yeah
yeah you featured
right and i think michael longfellow
hosted good memories that is yeah it's a
really good memory yeah uh i i don't
forget things and uh i was like this guy
has a level of energy on stage that you
know most people are like terrified to
even
bring out and then my second time which
was one of my favorite times of seeing
you was when
i j i just hadn't moved to la right and
my roommate at the time jessie johnson
just loved jesse of course uh
she was like she was like come with me
to the comedy store on monday nights
which i didn't know anything about the
comedy store know how it operated or
anything like that she's like
they do this thing in the main room
called kill tony and uh she was like
it's like a big thing and i was like
okay okay and i remember
walking in that day
and
it just it was like like this
i don't know it was like my first
experience of something big in comedy in
a town that i lived in okay you know
what i mean yeah if that makes any sense
no that makes sense yeah and in in the
fact that it was uh a variety
show like it was something different
especially on a monday special on a
monday and every bible i was like yo
there's a lot of people here yeah you
know like like that's awesome
we're used to hitting open mics and
stuff and yeah you're like oh there's
like five people here whatever and then
like that many people on a monday you're
like i didn't know that was possible i
did yeah exactly yeah and then uh i just
noticed a band and i want to say
the night i had came
malcolm hatchet had went up and i think
you guys had made him
uh the regular oh cool that was that was
the that was the night that that i had
saw but
i see you and i see you with the band
and and i'm like oh this guy [ __ ] can
do everything you know what i mean i was
like plays music but like like it was
it's fun watching you you know when you
guys were doing it obviously it's moved
to austin now but
we're watching you guys on stage
especially you when you you just like
you're all quick but like you have this
level of like
you know
quickness
with [ __ ] that is like dope to watch oh
okay
i don't know i just i mean i don't know
if people have ever told you that or
expressed that to you but it was one of
my favorite things favorite moments to
see and then i would consistently go
just to watch i never signed up you know
but i would go to watch because i always
thought it was like a dope experience
yeah just watching yeah we had a lot of
fun mondays in the main room yeah yeah
yeah you know sure so where so where
does your
musical
background come from like how did it
start you know
i mean i started playing sax uh when i
was like around third fourth grade and i
like sang in choir as a kid i did plays
i did all that stuff so i've always been
a very like you were that you were that
kid
yeah yeah yeah very active very active
and and what was it that very active
performance wise not sexually active at
all
just like theater let's go
oh
you're gonna touch my penis no thank you
no no get away no that's for marriage
you know so that was the kind of active
thing yeah no no uh
because i'm always so like how did you
get to saxophone because usually
initially like i'd say majority of
people it's either guitar or drums of
some sort
yeah you know i
i saw
somebody playing sax that it was lisa
simpson
lisa simpson no
you know the simpsons was one of those
weird shows where my dad would go in and
out of letting us watch that show really
he had weird like
he my dad has always gone like this with
religion where like
as a lot of people do where
they go like all in yes commit and
they're like no we are not going to have
any of that kind of trash in our house
or like
yeah they're watching it he's watching
it with me you know
like it goes all over the place so that
was one of those shows that would be
like touch and go like this month are we
not allowed to watch it or yeah are we
allowed to watch it you get it every
other month right right exactly uh but i
think i saw some i was i saw a saxophone
player at church actually okay and
that was the only sax of course at
church and i was like whoa that's
amazing so you were drawn to that yeah i
heard it and it sounded so different
from like you know the clarinets and
like just a piano and i think somebody
played trumpet and
he must have been putting a little stank
on those hymnals because
because i was like okay
okay that sounded good yeah you know
what i mean i was like what is this so
yeah i asked my mom
i asked i was like i want to play that
you want to take lessons you can you
want to
save up and
start you know
try to we had to rent a sacks from a
music store and did the lessons and then
like i shoveled driveways mowed lawns
like did a bunch of work and i finally
paid off the sacks like with my parents
yeah like this big deal i still have
that sex yeah you still have that sex
so so okay then um
because you you you don't just play sex
you play keys yeah play guitar uh yeah
yeah you know how many instruments can
you play total
i can i can play a handful i i play sax
uh piano and guitar the sax i've played
the longest uh piano's in my newest
instrument but i'm already better at
piano than i have ever been at guitar
guitar i can play chords and stuff yeah
yeah they did the natural chords yeah i
suck at keys i i can't [ __ ]
you know but i could play like in my
opinion if you if you have gotten down
guitar
piano might actually
you might be able to reverse engineer it
oh i never thought of that yeah since
you already know like chords on guitar
yeah yeah because all the chords are in
the same tuning and everything so it's
just it's just laid out yes it's just
like literally laid out the chords are i
don't know so i think piano is actually
easier than guitar
i can't i should i guess okay the first
song i'm gonna make it a challenge
and then i'll report it back yeah the
first song i'm going to learn
on the uh on the keys
will be no i was about to say purple
rain no i won't do that one uh
i think that's jumping a little too yeah
i mean that'd be i mean i think that's
just too high playing the chords i think
i was just trying to i was the most
unsexy version of purple right now i
think i was freaking out and i was like
say something and i was like
and then i stopped myself uh
you know i learned uh oh google dolls
i'll do a google doll song yeah yeah
i'll learn i'll learn uh that song slide
i like that song okay do you know that
song casey uh yeah no you don't i sure
do no you don't uh he doesn't know that
song so
so most of your life it's been
instruments
i have an ocd thing can you not put your
foot on the sacks oh my god
i'm like
my ocd was catching and i'm like i
literally i can't
i can't let it happen anymore what a
jerk
meanwhile this guy's pouring his heart
out about his about something i keep
seeing the foot being rest on him like i
can't i'm just he was did you see his
heart come out
and you're just gonna put your foot on
his that's not the first sax is it no
this is the upgraded one oh okay yeah
yeah you're lucky it's not that that
baby could you hand me that bottle
brother
thank you no no good thank you thank you
i just got to get some uh some water in
my system no make him feel bad uh we'll
make meatball feel bad for that one no
so um so yeah going back to where we're
at so yeah you play all these
instruments and then you sang in choir
okay and then
you also uh
did you play in the band in in school as
well uh
yeah yeah i did i played in the school
band and i played in the i played the
church band as well i remember being so
dedicated to the church's band like on
sunday mornings that i had sprained my
ankle and there was this long flight of
stairs and i managed to
jump up the stairs while wearing my
sacks like while i had a sprained foot
and i still played on that sunday
morning oh you you were that [ __ ]
committed baby i was in it and that's
what i that's that's the thing i love
about you like you commit and you go
full force and you attack everything as
best as you can like you you you let and
correct me if i'm wrong uh but you seem
like a guy
that
is like okay if i if i wanna do
something and i'm gonna do it
you're gonna go for it yeah i invest a
thousand percent yeah so like it's a big
deal when
i agree to do a project
either by myself or with somebody else
because it's like if we're gonna do this
i'm pouring all of myself into it so
like
you know we need to be like on the same
page if like you know like how scissor
bros started like we had that talk like
like hey like if this is happening like
we're going all the way in and like
we're putting
all the love into it all the effort into
it and luckily you know that's that's
been working out it's been cool yeah
it's it's great yeah because that's the
thing i've always been curious about
with you you know as i've as i've
watched you from from afar
i'm like man jeremiah just [ __ ]
he throws it all out there yeah you know
but you do it in a way that's like
a well-respected way
it doesn't seem like uh
chaotic or like or lacks authenticity
it's like no this is this is what no
it's definitely me it's like i i have
the way i look at like my comedy is like
the people who like it really like it
and then the people who are not into me
are really not into me and that's how
i'd like it to be because the worst
thing after a show that i can get is
that was all right that's literally i'd
rather have somebody be like i hated
that guy oh yeah hated that guy rather
than
that was an okay show yeah that's the
worst reaction to me oh i like that i
like that hate it so much i'd rather
have someone be like that was the best i
love it so much or like this dude sucks
sucked i hate him i don't understand how
he's headlining yeah yeah i'd rather
that yeah and be like hmm it wasn't all
right [ __ ] the gray area i give so much
that i'm like oh i'm giving you
everything so like yeah i'm wanting a
reaction
okay before we get into the stand up
because i want to get there too uh
so with
yeah um and then you did uh theater
okay
now
being a kid did you think about
because you're doing so many things did
you ever sit there and think like
well this i
did you ever think about narrowing it
down to something that you wanted to do
or were you just active because when
you're a kid like you obviously you
think you're like well i want i want to
do this i want to be this i want to be i
remember one time when i was a kid i
said i wanted to be a lawyer right the
[ __ ] oh yeah
i'm just talking i think uh as a kid
i mean honestly this is something that
i've really been working on the last
couple of years is
narrowing down uh okay uh because
when you put too much stuff out there
it becomes static at some point where
people don't it's just white noise uh
uh that's my stripper name is white
noise
[Laughter]
where you just you know the light you're
just putting it out there
it's just too much for people to focus
on oh white noise is here let's go
when you're putting out like a bun
because i do a lot of different things
people at the end of the day sometimes
it's a blessing and a curse
it was great me starting out doing a lot
of like these themed shows around l.a
like that i'm really have been grateful
to be a part of but after a while
you want somebody to know you like for
your stand-up so like after a while you
have to start kind of narrowing down
which i've been doing over the years is
like
i've slowly been
uh
no longer being a part of some of these
ensemble shows around la where it's
to kind of like put the blinders on
people where it's like this is what i do
if that makes sense yeah no that makes a
lot of sense but like looking at you you
you have so much uh to you
and um
especially when i've seen you do stand
up like when i saw you open for bobby
like you you're
you're good at utilizing all of your
abilities
on that stage yeah that's well that's
why i'm trying to like i'm like i've
done all these things and now i'm like
kind of trying to compile them to focus
people on like come see the stand-up
because i do all that stuff in the
stand-up if that makes sense yeah no no
no that that yeah but as a kid like my
mom instilled so much confidence in
those kids i was like i can do
everything you know yeah oh okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's where that
comes from yeah that's really yeah you
were just like yeah okay i've always had
too much confidence and you've always
been committed to what
[Laughter]
like i know he's as arrogant
unmerited
confidence like why does this guy have
so much confidence yeah it actually
drives some people crazy yeah no it's
it's it's awesome because you you
you're you're like
[ __ ] i'm gonna do what i'm gonna do
and you you're not i'm doing me yeah
hey
little drake in the house
he does do that a lot i'm doing me like
if i could get a drink gift uh
but uh no lies
so how do you block out
all the [ __ ] and stay committed
because you don't you don't seem to
think about anything that like
i mean i know we all like can get have a
little sensitivity in us you know
someone says something there comedians
are so much more freaking sensitive than
people
actually think yes yeah 100
but um you strike me as a as someone
that
uh
it's just like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
gonna do what i'm gonna do
you know yeah at the end of the day like
the the stuff that ends up like if i'm
no longer having fun doing something
it's got to go it's a it's as simple as
that you know what i mean because if i'm
not if it's not bringing me joy
how am i supposed to bring joy to other
people if i'm not feeling you're not
feeling it which with stand-up that
separates like you know the professional
from an amateur like we have to do shows
sometimes where we're sick or we're not
feeling good and
we have to bring laughs to an audience
but
just with projects in general
if you're not having fun doing like a
project
and you know
and the money like
there's only so much like like money can
only go so far or stuff and and if the
money's not good on top of that then
you're like why am i doing this yeah
you're like
if i'm not getting joy from this and
monetarily it's not like i'm doing a
cash grab or something like that it's
like it's gotta go it's gotta go yeah um
which i've had to think about a little
bit more like be a little bit more
selective with
as i you know get a little bit older and
like i have a family now it's like which
is so weird to say like i have a wife
and a baby you know what i mean so it's
it's you have to be a little bit more
business
uh with some of your decisions where for
the first 10 years i was in la i said
yes to literally every single thing
every single thing if somebody asked me
to do it whether it's a short film a
sketch you know come do this like play
sax on this random show like i bet yes
yes yes and now like over the years you
have to kind of like be more selective
which is weird but you just got to do it
yeah because there's only so much time
in the day one of my one of my favorite
things
i've heard you say
first of all before i say that
how did how did this stand up come about
how did this stand up come about yeah
how did how did how like how did that
come into your life
how did stand-up come into my life
because because the way that like when
you listen to your childhood it's like
musician theater it's like oh this guy
could do something you know go be on
broadway or you know he could be a
touring musician or whatever so we're
like
you never would think stand-ups are like
it's kind of like over here into the
world that you were in well while all
that stuff's going on i'm consuming
sketch comedy like crazy at the time
like snl and mad tv and like different
you know uh
you know sketch juggernauts and and
stand up all my favorite like
comedians like who like i found did
sketch or stand up and then you know you
just start exploring it and yeah then
you're like i want to do that like
that's because i you you know you
mentioned the lawyer thing i wanted to
be a pediatrician at one point
but
as a kid i looked up
when we were it was like
a career section at school i looked it
like at the end of the book to see who
was making the most money
do you know what i mean and like doctor
was like at one of the the top of the
list as far as professions that make
you know six figures and like and all
that so i mean that had a big part of it
but part of it was like i was like i
love making kids laugh okay so i was
like you know i want to be like that
patch adam's
doctor
oh you got cancer i got jokes let's go
if we don't get a photoshop of
jeremiah's patch house
no that's a that's amazing that's yes
and then you started in kansas kansas
city though
uh i started i just was taking like
improv classes in high school and
college uh and i had a couple teachers
that were
uh
impactful
with me that gave me words of
encouragement that like
i had one teacher who did some broadway
and he pulled me aside after one of the
classes he goes this is your thing
really he's like comedy is your thing
he's like improv
it's your thing like
i was like this guy's been on broadway
this is like he didn't have to tell me
that you know what i mean you're
searching you also like
when you're younger you're searching for
signs too you're like i just need any
kind of encouragement you know so but
like because
having a supportive family is amazing
i'm super grateful for that but it only
goes so far at the end of the day
because you need someone that has
no interest in you whatsoever or
no reason to give you
kudos for something that's why it's so
big like
at the comedy store like when a bigger
comic like which would say something
like hey funny set like
i still remember like one of the first
shows i did the comedy store like
10 11 years ago
uh
i had a great set in the main room of
the comedy store it was like a bringer
show and
comics were bombing left and right
because they were just bringing people
to perform there yep and like
yeah and leslie jones was one of the
pop-ins
and i had a killer set that night and
she walked by like all these comics who
had just bombed and then she sees me and
she goes
you were funny and then she kept walking
and i was like
yeah like that meant the world to me you
know i mean like little things like that
you just need like little nuggets
along the way that's interesting you say
that because uh
you know
i think that's a very respectful thing
for you to say to understand that yeah i
have support from my family
and they'll probably always support me
yeah but at the same time
like you need those outside forces
outside forces gotta gotta know that i'm
something too yeah cause that's how you
really know when you're something it's
like okay yeah that's cool my family
believes in me great it's kind of a kind
of a given right you know what i mean
for a family to believe in you yeah uh
but but
you know it's to my favorite thing that
i've ever heard you say it was at uh the
comedy store and i was stuck by this
uh and i don't even know if you remember
but you're i think you were hanging in
the hallway right before you were going
up and i can't remember who else was
there there's the third there was a
third comic there but uh i was just kind
of like sitting there listening uh
to you talk
and you talked about
you're like
you know if i'm bomb if like if i'm
bombing like i still have like another
like i have to fully commit because you
have so much
to your set to where you have these act
outs that are
massive and you were like
if i'm bombing i gotta [ __ ]
if this joke doesn't hit well there's
another one i gotta do that's another
act out so
it [ __ ] goes yeah you know what i
mean and i thought that was like
dope
you know what i mean because most people
were like oh well i guess i won't i
won't do that joke because they didn't
like this act out over here oh no you
mine my i am always a double down comic
oh you didn't like that you're really
not gonna like this next one yeah here
we go yeah yeah it's it's that it's that
confidence you were talking about
earlier you know and i'm glad i get i'm
getting to talk to you because like i
said i've always just watched this from
a distance and i go what what is the
[ __ ] root that's like my favorite
thing to learn about people especially
people that where where that comes from
yeah especially people that catch my
attention i'm like where is that like
how how
yeah you know
part of
and this i don't know if people have
ever asked you these kind of things
before not really like this
so i'm trying to like phrase it properly
yeah
it sounds
crazy it's because it like it sounds so
easy
but
it's a mixture of like
i mean a big part of a big part of my
confidence is i do come from a good
family
that is fair to say you know what i mean
that is very fair to say i have a mom
and dad that were encouraging to me
that
dude that does a heavy lifting on the
front half of your life yep if you have
people who are telling you you're great
over and over
and that like you can do whatever you
want that's huge so like
it's super important that you have
friends and family early on
but a lot of it like
i broke out of my shell like because i
was always like
funny to a point
when i started getting in trouble that's
when i would recoil but that's not the
funniest thing to do is you keep pushing
that's that's you know what i mean
it took me years to get so comfortable
where
now i can do stuff in public with
strangers where i don't care at all yeah
i i i can yell in public and do active
fool and
you know where some people be like oh
that's so crazy like
it doesn't really faze me anymore
because i've broken out of it and a lot
of that is
literally learned
like it's learning and shedding like
layers of like
that feeling that you know the hot
feeling that you get like in the back of
your neck or like your head when you're
embarrassed
it's literally like
feeling that
and then realizing
is that the worst that happened
it's me that that weird sensation
okay
and then just shedding that over and
over like a snakeskin
over and over and over and over until
you're just
a horrible person
and you don't care you don't care no
that's that's amazing because i i've
i've never heard
a something like that explained that way
you know when i think about i had an
opposite situation yeah you know as far
as like uh growing up with family and
stuff and
when i think about it yes i i do have
confidence
but
i've chilled out a lot more now but the
confidence i had before was carried with
like this guard
you know because i never
you don't you don't have a guard with
your confidence yeah if that makes any
sense of what i'm saying like i was
carrying it like yeah i'm going to
[ __ ] do it but also i'm carrying this
like
you know just [ __ ]
to it to where it it and all and almost
like
you know because if i did
fail at the thing that i attempted
then i would like feel bad
whereas like when i got rid of the guard
now i don't necessarily
feel that anymore i don't hold on to
that that
that failed
attempt
any anymore the the you know one of the
best lessons i i've learned about like
just being out in la a long time is
you know when you get an opportunity
that could change some things for you in
life
if you're having
fun and you're you're putting out like
what you consider good art and
everything at the moment yeah
when you get proposed with
these opportunities
don't be like if this happens then this
could change everything it's like
your life is already good enough where
it's at
so why
why hinge something on something that's
not like you already don't have that
thing you don't have it yeah so why are
you building this up like is this this
is the yeah it'd be nice to start on the
sitcom yeah yeah that'd be cool yeah
yeah but you don't have it is your life
doing all right yeah if it's in shambles
and you have that audition
then
you're probably not going to get it
anyway
oh wow you're probably not if you're
like that's beautiful that's beautiful
insight if you're like oh this this will
change everything like you're probably
it's probably not your time yet yeah
you probably need to still because the
amount of times i thought that i was
ready for stuff
when ready wasn't ready and most people
don't think about that no it's like most
of the times you just weren't
ready yeah and that's okay yeah that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean you're
not going to be
yeah you know what i mean it doesn't
mean you're not going to or cooking time
yeah it doesn't mean you're not going to
like make something like the confidence
thing for example i did not
date hardly at all in high school i was
very like i'm gonna do my short films
i'm gonna do my sketches i'm gonna do
music videos i'm gonna be artistic i
don't have time for girls that kind of
stuff right i [ __ ] love it
listen okay this is this way sound crazy
but i was just like that yeah yeah like
i i my first relationship is uh
uh with three uh my
current girlfriend now yeah the first
relationship i've ever had in my life
yeah we i mean we've been together three
three years i think or something like
that right uh
and but like my all my life i've just
like locked in
to like
what i wanted to do so to hear someone
else that was just like that yeah is
[ __ ] awesome yeah
and when the confidence thing the learn
thing that's why i said it sounds easy
or
it sounds crazy
but if you think about it this way i was
like when i moved to la i was like
i think i'm ready for a girlfriend
i literally just put that out there
i was like i think i'm ready to start
dating uh-huh and then
i ended up dating the girl who is my
wife now dude
do you know how crazy this is
we are ebony and ivory oh yeah we are we
are together we're perfect in harmony
yeah yeah
literally yeah cause
you know i've i've felt that way
you know and then literally when i moved
to la
i was just like you know what i think
i'm at a mature level i might find a
place in my life where i'm like this
could work for me yeah yeah
wow
do we just become best friends yes
now now now jeremiah
you know i i hear your uh
you know you do a
couple of uh well not a couple of uh
maybe a thousand of uh
impressions i did i do i do some
impressions yeah uh you know and i think
you do some
impressions of
you know musicians you know ideas being
chappelle's world and yeah you know a
lot of you know band stuff you know
and then with this wait there's a guitar
there's a guitar okay right here yeah
you know and uh
you know you know what
that
can i i'd say go for it yeah i'd say go
for it i'll i'll pull out the guitar
yeah you know i'm not the best guitar
player in the world but i do love it
doesn't matter if we're gonna have fun
but i have fun
dude
[Laughter]
dude i'm loving this [ __ ] episode by
the way meatball eat a dick don't you
ever put your foot on that
[Laughter]
uh you know
more so this year you know because of
the wonderful producer chin for fighter
and the kid yeah uh bring the shop show
on king of the sting
been listening to the country
okay you know and uh
you know one of the artists i like
i think he goes by the name of
luke bryan okay you know yeah and uh
you know i want to hang out with luke
and
you know i got i got i got a little i
got a little look there's your pal how
are you doing man oh
hey luke good to be here man
rain is a good thing yeah
country girls where are you at
so luke let's let's see what uh
what we can do with this you got some
kind of licks or something like that
maybe maybe uh
yellow some
[Music]
okay
if you're a country girl
around the world
i got something to say
get your pickup truck
go get your dog
on a tuesday
cause it's raining in my beer bottle
all night
i look in the mirror and i'm still white
i don't know
what to do
except make sweet sweet love to you
in the back of this pickup truck
you're gonna give me
a suck
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know that was a lot of fun chapelle
thanks for having me hey thanks for
stopping by luke i appreciate that
brother this is chappelle's
[Laughter]
oh world
you know uh
[Music]
i just like how it ended good to be a
suck
what a funny line
you're gonna you know give me a suck
yeah you know just give me a suck
don't give me a suck uh
you know what an artist i've always been
you know
fascinated by
uh
you know that i think you do another
impression of uh
you know a little little
a little more of a poppy
vibe to it yeah a little little
little smooth
little blue eyed man that used to have a
curly fro oh you know i think you know
who i'm talking about
we both we both share a love for this
man yeah i think his name's justin
timberlake
i don't know the way for justin but
we're gonna we're gonna roll with it
[Music]
oh wait you said give me yeah oh
hey what's up
it's me and your boy chapelle lacy on
the track
it's good to be here
maybe slow down a little bit like
start with that e minor
like strum it out a little bit more
[Music]
there we go
yeah it's feeling good now
oh
[Music]
can be you
oh jessica bill
you know you make me feel
so
good
oh
you're my wife oh girl you're my life
and i got so many babies with you
oh
yeah girl you make up me cheating
but i promise that i won't be repeating
[Music]
it was a one-time deal
and i copped the feel
and i'm so
sorry girl
you're my world
[Laughter]
hey justin thank you so much for having
me chappelle i appreciate that hey
justin just just you know
treat your wife good
i will thank you
that's a good one
so uh justin
i think
uh oh justin sorry that was so that was
another one uh i i think i think i want
to do one more all right i think i think
we're gonna go with the rule of three
and comedy you know okay uh and we got
we got to do a third one
um
listen
this this guy he's been around for
for decades
you know
and he he loves the state of california
all right i think he sings about it a
lot yeah yeah yeah i think i know you're
talking about
um
[Music]
yo
yeah the nikki this
[Music]
where are you from oh sorry i [ __ ] up
that court it's okay
[Music]
yeah i'm from the state of california
how many times i
gotta warn ya
[Music]
i've been here for so
long
[Laughter]
before girls walk far
around
[Music]
i saw a pretty little baby in a mundane
do
and i saw a guy
he was a jew i don't know why i'm
singing about the jews in california
jews in california
here we go
[Music]
california
i must warn you if you're not from
california yeah you gotta hit the high
highway
take the ten or the seventy
[Laughter]
somewhat
all right that was all right i don't
know how to play uh like john uh
what's his name first
i don't know how to pronounce his last
day but that was uh that was amazing to
be able to collaborate
with a few artists with a few artists
yeah you know
that that [ __ ]
i can't do impressions
i i told you uh how do you like how do
you
how the [ __ ] do you like what
i've been able to mimic since i was a
little kid i i didn't i told you do my
voice
[Laughter]
i've never had somebody say
do me and then they do an impression of
themselves following
right after that
like i'm gonna help you out a little bit
you don't have to do my you don't have
to do my voice i don't know anyone that
could imitate it
yeah
but yeah
keep talking for a little bit uh so you
know one time when i was a kid so one
time when i was a kid oh that's pretty
good that's pretty good
[Laughter]
damn i didn't know i had a little shack
vibe to me a little bit right yeah you
heard that
hey hey guys welcome to chappelle's room
guys
so i'm thinking
a little bit jeremiah so at the end of
every episode i like to do
rapid [ __ ] questions but also we're
going to close out
with a jam but we're going to do these
rabbit questions
and then i also do
yeah rapid [ __ ] questions
and then uh we oh oh also i like to
create a soundtrack to each episode that
people can listen to to get a vibe of
the episode because when i was younger
and when i would watch dawson's creek
so at the end of every episode of
dawson's creep
they would give you the songs they
played throughout the episode okay so
we'll we'll do that at the end but rapid
questions first favorite band
say muse ooh
solid solid choice
favorite concert you've attended
i'll say spoon
spoon or oh this is hard or linkin park
that was really good i saw them live
that was that was a pretty amazing
incredible yeah yeah yeah i might say
lincoln park okay lincoln park yeah
favorite album
oh
um
[Music]
this is a hard one
uh this is a
i mean this is a little bit of a cop-out
but this is the the beatles one
anthology no that's fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah if it makes you feel if you're
having fun
[Laughter]
and
we didn't get to talk about this but you
have written some songs you have some
music videos that are on
uh youtube that you put out yeah put out
quite a few
uh what is your favorite song that you
have written
um it's in
there's one called you gotta have fun
that i that i really enjoyed that we're
talking about i mean we're talking about
fun a lot of things you see what he did
uh you check that out there is it is it
on that one's on youtube that's on
youtube there's a music video for that
there's a song that uh is unreleased
that i'll release eventually called
secrets that's um i really like that
song a lot that that'll i just need to
the music thing is a different that's a
different confidence level
to put out stuff as a comedian and like
be like this is not funny yeah
so like what is
so like you know
it
i need to release it but i also would
have to like shoot a music video or a
lyric video or something for it but
it's being mixed right now so yeah
i can't wait to hear it i would love to
hear it yeah i love that like i said i
love that you go for everything and you
you like you said you're full-on
committed to everything you [ __ ] do
yeah and uh uh go check out the song
uh which one's the one that you just
said you gotta have fun you gotta have
fun okay that's on youtube just it's not
funny it's just a song yeah it's just a
song and it's jeremiah watkins you gotta
have fun yeah yep so do that all right
so we do like 12 songs
okay what is this uh i'll start off i'll
go with uh google dolls slide
yeah
so this is the playlist that will
accompany this episode right yep okay
and it doesn't have to be if if we
didn't mention the artist or whatever if
you felt the vibe or whatever
then you throw it up there
i mean i think we have to put down ebony
and ivory oh yeah oh yeah we do
yeah um that yeah
yeah
what's that song uh they did quite a few
together
uh
michael jackson and paul mccartney did
the girl is mine
i think it's called the girl is mine
yeah okay
cause that's us
you're paul mccartney i'm michael well
[Laughter]
i like that man well because i felt bad
cause i was like well what if he wanted
to do michael's part and i and he wanted
me to do you know i felt like i jumped
the gun
you know that's what they don't talk
about what if a white guy wants to be
something on halloween
it's always the other the other point of
view i can't be this white character
what if i want to be a black guy
what's going on
why can't i do it
um
let's see i think
uh
arctic monkeys this is another band that
i just love yeah um
uh why'd you only call me when you're
high
good one yeah yeah i'm friends with the
drummer he's been on here matt helgens
oh really yeah yeah he's amazing
sweetest [ __ ] guy that's another
impression that i love doing just
because it's like i just love that band
that's one of my favorite bands oh
really yeah well i did not know that
yeah you learned something new every day
there you go uh he did arctic monkeys
why'd you only call me when you're high
i'll do
[Music]
gosh it's gonna kill me if i don't know
this muse song
because you mentioned muse oh yeah
where's my phone
we're talking about uh i think is it
pronounced mineskin before this oh yeah
i'm begging i'm begging begging you
to put your lovers out baby
i'm baby that'll be my song thank you
goodbye i love your hair
baby
he's probably a little dude too probably
because that's a big voice yeah i
watched the the the music video he was
like wearing makeup and stuff i was like
did not expect that to come out of that
i was like okay okay there you go uh
vegan veganu
yeah yeah i'll do i'll do that one
yeah you don't have to spell it i will
figure it i i'll know i'll know that
when you send me a playlist i know it
um
justin timberlake summer love
ooh good one yeah
damn you're talking to me
he's got a lot of uh great hits i'll do
jt senorita
i was thinking about this sound is
heating up can i leave
oh ooh
justin came back
[Laughter]
senorita
here for you ever you
do the things that you want me to
you're like a true fan of justin i love
jesus same yeah good good come on man
i'm glad i'm glad you're a big fan
[Laughter]
well how many we have eight
six seven what was it seven seven
uh
so you go
uh let's see here
um
well i mentioned spoon uh earlier oh yes
you spoon i turn my camera on it's one
of my favorite songs okay have you ever
heard that song
if you're
listening you haven't heard that song
it's a good one the music video is dope
too it's very ulti very weird yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna go with since we
mentioned linkin park yeah i'll go with
uh
i really love
the way you spelled it i really
[Music]
abraham lincoln
[Laughter]
scored seven years ago they're like
abraham
about depression lincoln
gives me anxiety
he's got a spell and we see what his
spelling's like he's just like
he's like oh my favorite band is uh you
know
diarrhea velcro oh you know uh the song
by lincoln park that i that i want to
put is onomatopoeia
i'm just kidding
uh
we'll do actually you just felt it wrong
because the underlying under tells you
that you felt the wrong i'll do breaking
the habit
that's the one where it has like the uh
the music video
yeah they're like uh
it's like a cartoon
yeah i love that song
yeah
that's a good one
and we'll do one more you'll close it
out
uh just because uh
uh they did a study and this is
considered we're talking about fun and
just being happy and and like trying to
be content with your life and stuff
uh they did a study and this is the
happiest song
that's been ever created
and it's mr blue sky
really
they they said that's the happiest song
that
it gives endorphins
to people and literally improves their
mood when they hear the song really
now
it could have just been a weird internet
article that i read
but
it's kind of an interesting fact if
that's the case
do you know that song
blue sky please tell us why
that's so true it's a happy one
yeah that is so true it's a good one i
go to this vegan spot and and it has
this i don't know if it's just like this
consistent playlist but i hear that song
every time i go to that that restaurant
there you go and it
like it never fails i'm making you feel
good yeah
jeremiah walkers everybody jeremy pick
up that sex let's close it out man all
right let's let's that's it
let's let the cred let's let the credits
roll thank you bro you
know
jeremiah's going to play us play us out
what do you want me to play you play
whatever your heart desires he's good at
this [ __ ]
you know
meatball yeah get get that get that
behind for the behind the scenes
oh even that sounded good
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
that was [ __ ] amazing
go see oh go see jeremiah uh support his
his stuff his podcast jeremiah wonders
uh subscribe to that uh scissor bros
with stevie wiebe subscribe to that the
wildest [ __ ] dudes ever uh anything
and everything he's doing uh this
releases on thursday so you got any tour
dates you want to throw out there
scissor bros live on the east coast in
pennsylvania jeffersonville pennsylvania
this saturday january 8th yeah and uh
i'm on tour constantly got uh
indianapolis des moines i'm in houston
at the end of the month we're doing a
stand up on the spot taping there as
well as i'm headlining three shows so
come see me man yes he has a wonderful
show stand up on the spot and i think
there's a video on youtube uh where you
guys did like a stand-up on the spot
yeah i did this stand up on the spot
special it's got shane gillis on it
akash
akashing um uh ian fidenz yes it's got
it's got quite a few people
support this man support what he does
he's an amazing dude very kind heart and
uh you know thanks for thanks for
[ __ ] coming dude dude love you
brother